-Hello, everyone, and welcome
back to my attic crawl space.
We have been focusing a lot
on that mysterious
tiny little door over there.
And we're taking guesses
for what's behind it
at whatsupwithsethstinydoor
@gmail.com.
Again, it's very unlikely
we will ever check that account,
let alone read any of it
on the air.
But, you know,
what else are you doing?
Now, I've also noticed there
has been some speculation online
about another aspect
of our makeshift setup here,
"The Thorn Birds."
Of all the books in my house,
why did I choose to highlight
this 1977 Australian romance
novel that was later adapted
into a hit 1983 television
mini-series?
Have I actually read it?
If so, why?
Am I secretly 78 years old?
Maybe I'm not actually
at my house,
but my parents' house.
Or maybe I just want to prove
to everyone
that on top of being
a well-known bibliophile
who is up on the latest
literary trends,
I am also an old soul
who loves a steamy read
about a torrid affair
between an innocent farm girl
and a hot priest.
Anyway, if you have any guesses,
send them
to whydidsethpickthethornbirds
@gmail.com.
there is almost no way we'll
read anything you send us.
But you know, what the hell?
You can either spend your time
doing that
or trying to recover the
password to your workout app,
giving up, and taking
a three-hour bath,
like the rest of us.
And while are you're doing that,
the president and his allies
are trying to wish away
the coronavirus pandemic
and hoping you'll forget
that he badly botched
his response to the crisis.
For more on this it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As we have seen throughout
his presidency,
Donald Trump is both an emblem
and an enabler
of a broken government.
And that government
has put lives at risk
with its arrogance
and incompetence.
For example, at one of his
daily press conferences
this week, as the U.S.
was continuing to face down
a deadly coronavirus spreading
rapidly throughout the country,
he bristled when the word
"testing" came up
and complained that it wasn't
the federal government's job
to test people.
-Testing is still a big issue
in this country.
When can hospitals expect --
-Put the slide up again, please.
-When can hospitals expect
to receive a quick turnaround
of its test results?
-Are you ready? Are you ready?
Hospitals can do
their own testing, also.
States can do their own testing.
States are supposed
to be doing testing.
Hospitals as opposed to be doing
testing.
Do you understand that?
We're the federal government.
Listen,
we're the federal government.
We're not supposed to stand on
street corners doing testing.
-Trump thinks testing
happens on street corners,
because if he weren't president,
he'd definitely be selling
fake tests
on street corners right now.
He'd be set up in Times Square
with a bunch of Q-tips laid out
on a black folding table.
[ As Trump ] Who needs swabs?
We got your swabs here.
What? No, lady,
they're not Q-tips,
they're high quality
medical swabs.
Look, if you're not buying,
just move on.
I got a lot of customers here.
[ Normal voice ]
Also if you don't mind,
I want to go back
to this part --
-Are you ready? Are you ready?
-It's such a dickhead move to
ask someone if they're ready,
like you're about to blow
their minds.
He's like a guy sitting at a
piano saying, "Check this out!"
And then pecking out
"Chopsticks" at half-speed.
I also love the sheer audacity
of this guy
asking someone else
if they're ready.
Remember, Trump is the guy
who in just four years,
went from this...
-I alone to fix it.
-...to this.
-And we're backup.
Remember we're a backup.
-Trump thought he alone
could fix it
until he saw what it was.
It's like when you used
to go on road trips
with your buds
and your car would break down.
You had that one friend
who was always like,
"Hey, pop the hood. I got this."
And then you know,
just stand there for a while,
hands on his hip looking at it.
Then he'd finally say,
"Damn, there's a lot
of stuff under here.
You have AAA?"
And now, as the outbreak
continues to intensify
and the death toll mounts,
NPR reports that
the federal government
will end funding for coronavirus
testing sites this Friday.
In a few places, those sites
will close as a result.
You think now is the time
to cut off funding for tests?
Are you insane?
It's like getting halfway
through surgery
taking the guy's spleen out
and saying,
"All right. You can wake him up.
He can sew himself back
together.
That's the easy part."
And then today we learned
roughly 17-million people
have lost their jobs
in just three weeks
as the death toll passed 15,000.
And yet, Trump is once again
rushing to pretend
this will all go away and hoping
people will forget that,
as we detailed yesterday,
he literally ignored
years of warnings
about the threat of a pandemic.
-Ultimately the goal
is to ease the guidelines
and open things up to very large
sections of our country
as we near the end
of our historic battle
with the invisible enemy.
There's tremendous hope
as we look forward
and we begin to see the light
at the end of the tunnel.
-"Once we open up
our great country,
and it will be sooner
rather than later,
the horror
of the invisible enemy,
except those that sadly lost
a family member or friend,
must be quickly forgotten."
-[ Sighs ]
I love that
"Hold a Grudge Jones" over here
is telling us we have to
forget it and move on.
The same guy who is still
so mad at John McCain
that he tweeted McCain
was last in his class
at Annapolis
seven months after he died.
This [bleep] is the same
as people who act terribly
and then when you point out
their terrible behavior,
cry, "What of civility?"
Civility isn't a right.
It's earned.
And sometimes people
don't deserve it.
Just like some people don't
deserve their bad decisions
to be lost to history.
And nothing gives away the game
of how badly Trump
has handled this
like Trump telling us now
we have to forget about it
when it's over.
During World War II,
Winston Churchill
wasn't thinking,
"I never want to hear
about this again."
He was champing on a cigar
thinking,
"When this is over, there
are gonna be a million books
about how hard I crushed
this [bleep]"
You know, or however
he would say it.
Probably like this.
[ Muttering ]
It would be like that, would --
That would like, preface it.
I mean,
who should all forget about it?
Trump is like an employee
at Wendy's who gets fired,
shows up drunk
in the middle of night,
takes a [bleep]
in the Frosty machine,
scribbles "Donald was here,"
and passes out naked
in the parking lot.
When the cops come to arrest
him, he says,
[ Chuckling ]
"Guys, that was only yesterday.
Let's move on."
Also stop telling people there's
a light at the end of the tunnel
before there is actually a light
at the end of the tunnel.
No one who actually knows
anything about this
says we are going back to normal
until there is a vaccine,
which takes at least
a year to 18 months.
Just listen to
Dr. Anthony Fauci.
-When you gradually come back,
you don't jump into it
with both feet.
You say, you know,
what are the that things
that you can still do
and still approach normal?
One of them is absolute
compulsive hand washing.
The other one is you don't
ever shake anybody's hands.
[ Chuckles ] That's clear.
The other thing,
depending upon your status,
the possibility that when
are you in a group of people,
that you can't avoid
the 6-foot limit
and you can't stay
out of 10 feet,
that you might want to wear
a cloth face protection.
-The toughest part about that --
Son of a bitch.
Is there a second
"Thorn Birds" now?
What in the world?
Sorry. The toughest part of
that advice for Donald Trump
is the no handshakes rule.
Because as we've seen from
his meetings with world leaders,
he locks on to them with a death
grip and would not let go.
Remember how long he clung
to French President
Emmanuel Macron?
I'm pretty sure they had to be
surgically separated.
That is a man desperate
for human contact.
One of these days, Trump
is gonna pull Macron in
for a handshake and slap
on a pair of handcuffs.
[ As Trump ]
Uh-oh! Oh, look at this.
And, oh, no, I accidentally
swallowed the key.
I guess we have to be
best friends for life.
So tell me,
do you really eat snails?
[ Normal voice ] And then there
is the advice about masks.
Now we know Trump does not
take medical advice.
That much is clear.
I mean, look at him.
He looks like he gets
his fake tan
by sticking his face
in the microwave.
That's either
a terrible fake tan
or the world's largest freckle.
And Trump certainly doesn't
listen to actual doctors.
Instead, he listens to TV idiots
like Sean Hannity.
At one point, Trump admitted
he got his information
about ventilators
from watching Hannity.
And on his radio show,
Hannity referred to himself
as Dr. Hannity.
-I just saw on your show
and a couple of other people
just reported back to me
that everyone is in great shape
from the standpoint
of ventilators.
-I would, based on all I know,
Dr. Hannity --
Dr. Hannity,
I'm my only patient.
I would absolutely use it
if I got this.
-Ugh. People always
get this wrong.
You're not Dr. Hannity,
you're Dr. Hannity's Monster.
I'm sorry.
You are not qualified to give
anyone medical advice.
You look like you've only ever
had one medical procedure,
and that was to have your neck
removed.
Trump listens to fake doctors
more than he listens
to his real medical doctors.
For example, after the CDC
officially recommended
that every American wear a mask
or a face covering
when going outside to slow
the spread of the coronavirus,
Trump announced
the new guidelines
from the White House podium
and then immediately
contradicted them.
-The CDC is advising the use
of non-medical,
cloth face covering
as an additional voluntary
public-health measure.
So it's voluntary.
You don't have to do it.
They suggested it
for a period of time.
But this is voluntary.
I don't think
I'm going to be doing it.
-In a way, it makes sense
since Trump's face
already looks like a mask.
One of these days
he's going to rip that thing off
and reveal he's actually Bodhi
from "Point Break."
It's a "Point Break" reference.
Seriously,
what is wrong with you?
You can't announce
a new public-health measure
to stem the tide of a pandemic
and then immediately say
you're not going to do it.
Can you imagine him proposing
to a woman?
[ As Trump ]
Will you marry me and make me
the happiest man on Earth?
For a while, anyway.
I don't want to get tied down.
You know what?
We should see other people.
Or at least, I should
see other people.
You are welcome to stay
faithful to me.
The CDC even recommends it.
[ Normal voice ] And not only
does Trump ignore doctors,
he thinks he knows more
than they do.
Remember when he visited
the CDC headquarters
in the hat and windbreaker
and held up a printout
like a gym teacher subbing in
for a science class?
"Check this out.
It's a -- I don't know.
It's a germ,
something like that.
It looks like it's called
Wikipedia.
Anyhow, quiet down!
We're gonna spend the rest of
the class watching "Bull Durham"
on LaserDisc."
And then he claimed that
because his uncle was smart,
his uncle was smart,
he personally knew a lot
about coronavirus.
-And I like this stuff.
You know,
my uncle is a great person.
He was at MIT.
He taught at MIT for,
I think, like a record
number of years.
He was a great super-genius.
Dr. John Trump.
I like this stuff.
I really get it.
-No, you don't.
You look like you wandered
into the middle of a press
conference from a tour.
He should be holding a map
with a Nikon camera
around his neck asking
the scientists for directions.
[ As Trump ] You guys know
how to get to Times Square?
I wanna buy some swabs.
I hear it's the real deal.
[ Normal voice ]
So, you don't even know
what your uncle taught
or how many years he taught,
but you know he was
a great super-genius?
Was your uncle Wile E. Coyote?
[ As Trump ] Taught at MIT
for a record number of years.
But he could never catch
the Road Runner.
You know, he's the one
that told me
there was a light
at the end of a tunnel.
A real tunnel.
Not one painted onto the side
of a mountain.
[ Normal voice ]
That was the day that Trump said
anyone who wants a test
will get a test.
And now he's cutting funding
for testing.
And I know he'd prefer it
if we were all Drew Barrymore
from "50 First Dates"
and we'd wake up every morning
and say, "President Trump?
Oh, I'll give that a chance."
But that's not how
most of our brains work.
We remember the things
you've said
and then we hold you to account
for them.
It now it looks like our chance
to do that will be in November
in a race between Trump
and Joe Biden
after Bernie Sanders officially
dropped out of
the presidential race yesterday,
Which sucks for
a ton of reasons.
One of which is the timing
on Medicare For All.
Would have been pretty [bleep]
great right now,
given that we're going through
a massive healthcare emergency
in which millions of people
are also losing
their health insurance.
Maybe we are finally
all learning now
that tying your healthcare
to your job was a stupid idea.
I mean, what do they have to do
with each other anyway?
If we really wanted
to make healthcare
commensurate with your job,
then nurses, delivery workers,
and grocery clerks would get
free gold-plated healthcare
for the rest of their lives
and racist game show hosts
would have to pay
a million bucks
to replace every tooth
that falls out.
-God bless the United Shates.
-You have to admit, Bernie
fundamentally changed politics.
And he did it in the course
of like five years.
Let's just remember how
extraordinary this was.
I mean, his first campaign
began in 2015
when he wandered up to
reporters, I guess in a park,
and told them he was running
for president and also
that he was too busy
to talk to them.
-Thank you all very, very much,
whoa, for being out here today.
Let me just make a brief
comment,
and I'll be happy
to take a few questions.
We don't have an endless amount
of time. I've got to get back.
-I'm so bummed we passed up
on the chance for a president
who hated pomp and circumstance
as much as Bernie did.
His State of the Unions would
have been 10 minutes tops.
[ As Sanders ] Please, hold
your applause until the end.
Or, you know, hold it entirely.
I don't care much for empty
displays of enthusiasm.
When old people give standing
ovations, it's very silly.
[ Normal voice ] I mean,
he walked up to them
like he had been in that park
all night.
[ As Sanders ] Get out of here.
You're scaring the birds.
It's a very delicate ecosystem.
Also, he personally covered
that podium himself
and decided to stop
after making the top.
Who needs a full podium?
It's too ostentatious.
And in a fitting way, Bernie
bookended his two campaigns
for president with
an announcement in a park
and a fiery speech from
the Senate floor last month
in which he fought to protect
extra pay for workers
who lost their jobs
due to the pandemic.
-And now I find that
some of my Republican colleagues
are very distressed.
They are very upset
that somebody who's making
10, 12 bucks an hour,
might end up with a paycheck
for four months
more than they received
last week.
Oh, my God,
the universe is collapsing.
Imagine that -- Somebody who's
making 12 bucks an hour
now, like the rest of us,
faces an unprecedented
economic crisis
with the 600 bucks
on top of their normal,
their regular unemployment
check,
might be making a few bucks more
for four months.
Oh, my word!
Will the universe survive?!
-Sarcastic Bernie
is the best Bernie.
I think it's
his Brooklyn accent.
He's like an old-timer
working a shift
at the Park Slope Food Coop
dealing with snooty newcomers.
"Excuse me, there is no more
organic arugula."
[ As Sanders ] Oh, my word!
You have to make your fancy
salads with regular arugula.
Imagine that. How will
the universe survive?!
[ Normal voice ] We need
those kinds of major changes
to deal with
the broken government
that Trump is currently
exposing.
He ignored years of warnings
about a possible pandemic,
lied about it when it arrived,
forfeited responsibility
to the states,
pushed an unproven miracle cure,
and is now asking us to just
forget the whole thing.
And if you beg him
to provide leadership,
he responds by saying...
-I don't think
I'm gonna be doing it.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
Three?
♪♪
City Harvest
is such a great charity,
and now they're working hard
to support New York City
families who are out of work
due to the COVID-19 pandemic.
If you're watching this online,
please hit the "Donate" button,
give what you can.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.